what i want to show you now is a way to
add numbers or a way that i sometimes
add numbers when i'm doing it in my head
so let's say i want to add 5 to 68 and
we've already seen other ways of doing
it so what i'm showing you in this video
isn't the only way to do it but it might
be helpful when you're doing it in your
head when i look at a number like 68 i
think well gee if i if i added just 2 to
that i would get to 70. so why didn't i
break up 5 into
3 and 2 add the 2 to 68 and then i have
to add the 3. so what's that going to
get me well if i break up the 5 into 3
plus 2 and the whole reason why i broke
it up into 3 and 2 is so i have this 2
here to add to 68 so 5
is 3 plus 2
and to that i'm going to add 68
and once again the reason why i put took
this 2 out is because i said hey what do
i have to add to 68 to get to 70.
so now i could just rewrite this as
plus 2
plus 68
but now i can add the 2 to the 68.
so 2 plus 68 is going to be
2 plus 68 is 70.
70 and i still have this 3 here so i
have 3 plus 70 which is equal to
now it might seem like this really long
way of doing it but this is just a way
to think about it in your head you would
say okay 5 plus 68 let's see if i add 2
to 68 i'll get to 70. and so let's see 5
is 3 plus 2 i add the 2 to 68 i get to
70 and i have 3 left over so it's going
to be 73.
another way you could think about it is
on a number line so let's draw ourselves
a number line here
let's draw a number line and let me draw
some
let me draw some tick marks here
and let's say that this right over here
this right over here is
and
so this is going to be 70.
this is going to be
70. and we're going to add 5.
we're going to add 5.
so if you add 5 you say well let me add
2 first
so if i add 2 first i get to 70. so plus
2 and that's what i did right over here
to get to 70 and then if i if i want to
add 5 then i have to add three more
then i have to add three more
and so it's going to be 70 plus three
which of course is
73 hopefully you found that interesting